[Applaudissements]
mon blake n franchement terre d'amour
merci vous exclut télé qu'elle exclut
totalement
ça y est j'ai l'impression que tout le
monde est dans le clip là c'est un truc
de tout le monde et dans les philippe
avoir avant mais ça y est les vins qui
peut aller les voir ou non mais facile
face il fallait prévoir et chérie j'ai
un mec est allé voir un haka les voir
bouger vraiment pas hop on peut tous
faire un arrêt facile regarder ses
messages tout bas vas-y vas-y vas-y je
peux twitté il est 8 heures je vais
écrire je kiffe blake n va cd est pas
mon plat comme black m
éternel insatisfait c'est nouvel album
cet album de black et bien sûr que vous
connaissez le clip est ennuyé vif et
merci d'avoir été avec nous sur ces vite
tout de suite c'est rocky balboa merci
black and avoir été avec nous mais
rester sur ces vite on vous aime fort et
n'oubliez pas la télé c'est que de la
télé merci je suis tout seul et surtout
se figer et si on termine émission comme
ça s'allume et chéri joe